[Music]
recent 45-day
cgm that's continuous glucose monitor
experience
why did you decide to use a continuous
glucose monitor and what did you learn
from that experience
why because
i i'm kind of a bit obsessed over like
the physiology
of my own body and what and what are the
things that drive that physiology
whether it be sleep or cold plunging or
fasting or diet and
having the ability to
test and learn around my dietary choices
wasn't so intriguing to me and
once it was available and i knew it was
out there
i reached out to
frank littman who's a doctor i kind of a
friend and a doctor that i go to see in
new york
and he he
figured out a way to get a cgm on my arm
and uh
so i did it just sheer at a sheer
curiosity and
and a desire to just kind of like
you know it's so cliche to say this but
just kind of optimize my diet a bit and
understanding blood sugar i totally buy
in to
level blood you know keeping blood sugar
levels
steady
i think is hugely critical to all kinds
of health
so what did you learn what were the
biggest takeaways i'll tell you the
craziest biggest takeaway that i feel
like
should be on that billboard you might
ask me about you know it won't but but
it's like take a walk after you eat
it is astonishing
how can it be that i've never heard that
in my whole life yeah
that should be like taught in first
grade
because the effect of it the effect of
it is insane and and i saw it firsthand
and i think that the folks at levels are
seeing it more and more and more because
it's get this message is getting out as
they accumulate data
but the power of a 14-minute walk
to
reduce the spike of your blood sugar
regardless of what you eat
is extraordinary
wow no kidding and so you used levels in
this experiment i did
that's incredible why 14 minutes
is that the length of your favorite guns
and roses no i'm just did i say 14 or 50
just like a short a short me you know
just a little walk it okay ten minutes
maybe five minutes i didn't really test
the length of the walk but it's like it
was nothing severe it was just that
exercise it's not like going to the gym
or doing push-ups just going for a walk
around the block yes totally chill
walk around the block
and i couldn't believe it and
it's it's amazing to me so
highly highly recommend that it should
be taught everywhere because it's
incredibly effective
that's wild man you know i haven't
thought you just prompted something to
come to my mind which i haven't thought
of
in a few decades and i'm going to
apologize to anyone who hears this and
unders kind of understands what i'm
saying
because i'm going to probably butcher it
because my tones are off these days but
there's a there's a i want to say well
maybe it's not so much a proverb it's a
expression in mandarin chinese which is
something like
fun ho by
which is
if you walk 100 steps after you eat you
will live to be 99.
that's literally the expression
that's amazing yeah and it's just like
huh turns out a few thousand years of
trial and error yeah how did you find
that expression tim i mean i was living
in china and uh i
this is a long time ago i mean this is
1996
so this is back when beijing was like
people's liberation green army jackets
in the winter these green jackets and
bicycles right so beijing is a different
city now and
i was there for six months to
universities
and
i mean that was kind of the last time i
studied chinese was around that time
but
you just saying that prompted that to
pop up in my brain which is why i'm
telling you there's a lot there's a lot
there for sure i mean that was my
experience and many others and it's just
i find it fascinating and
sitting here in 2021 and like i've been
kind of
embedding myself and trying to learn
about
you know nutrition and and health and
you know we we have some mutual friends
and people we follow and uh and it's
just amazing to me that i've never
i've never come across that
yeah how wild what else any other
insights that you gleaned from your
experiment yep the other big one was to
combine the macronutrients like
if you if you just eat us if you just
eat a carb or a a complex carb or a
simple carb by itself
as opposed to eating it alongside fat
and protein
so this idea of like a well-rounded
plate
that made a huge difference as well and
one night in particular i uh it was it
was a fun it was a fun game too having
this thing on my arm by the way so one
night out you know i went and i had a
business dinner at hearth and um and i
was kind of like i approached it with
this idea of like you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna like eat everything
and i'm gonna eat a lot of it right so i
went kind of nuts and i just ate all the
things like garlic breads and wine and
cocktails and and desserts and like i
just i probably consumed 3000 calories
right and i was like i want to see if i
could make my levels like blow up and
the astounding thing was because it was
like a lot of fiber and a lot of protein
and a lot of fat in addition to all the
bad simple carbs and sugars and wines
and all that i didn't spike that high
and i think it's because
having fiber and having fat and having
protein alongside
these bad players of simple carbs and
sugar
helps mitigate that spike
huh did you exercise earlier in the day
by any chance do you know yeah my
exercise is always i don't i'm i'm uh
i'm a exercise first thing kind of guy
yep although my lifestyle is active
because i live in you know in new york
i'm always on my feet and i'm walking a
lot right so
that must play into things as well
fascinating it was i loved having that
thing on my arm i kind of want to do it
again because
there's so much cool testing and
learning you can do
you